you just made this movie with Tracy and  I'm curious  that means hours and hours and hours of  doing scenes with him and I imagine it's  hard to keep a straight face when you're  doing a scene with this man well it's  easy for me to keep a straight face  because I'm always trying to go home the  guy panda stick with the bone we got it  Roger give me that look that means shut  it down Tracy does he come prepared is  he ready to go as he professional um  except for when he has to pronounce you  know difficult words like anomaly wait a  minute wait a minute I'm not used to  using those words in the ghetto some  people don't use the word anomaly in the  gap then we don't even use words like  hypothetical you can say that's a  [ __ ]  [Applause]